[Musik]
frau zimmermann hat gerade gesagt es
gibt schulen die sind einfach zu eng
also da kann man diese abstandsregeln
gar nicht einhalten sollten diese
schulen ihrer meinung nach einfach
geschlossen bleiben
also bleibt die frage stellt sich
insbesondere dann wenn wir schon
akzeptieren also jetzt glaube ich gibt
es kaum die schule die nicht genügend
räume hat und die als an meine eigenen
schule
leider sind normalerweise 900 schüler
jetzt kommen dass jetzt die 50
abiturienten zurück das ist nicht das
problem und an den meisten anderen
schulen auch nicht aber in der tat bin
dann zusätzliche jahrgänge zurückkommen
und wir haben schlechte bauliche
voraussetzungen die toilettenanlagen
wenig waschgelegenheiten dann in der tat
ist die frage wie kann das noch
funktionieren weil dann allmählich die
räume ausgehen und übrigens hatte ja
kräfte ausgehen
wie kann das funktionieren also ich
komme mir nur ein oder zwei stellen und
zwar dass wir dann auch weiterhin keinen
vollen unter richtigen mal so wenn
zusätzlich jahrgangsstufen ziehen dann
müssen wir auch halbierten unterricht
zum beispiel machen vielleicht sogar
weniger
was übrigens dass das cooling begleitend
noch viele wochen wahrscheinlich viele
monate
na dann stattfinden muss wenn ich jetzt
mal davon ausgeht dass die schätzungen
der gesundheitsexperten richtig sind
dass es noch ein jahr dauern könnte dann
müssen wir uns auch mindestens ein jahr
noch an den schulen mit erheblichen
einschränkungen auf erhebliche
einschränkungen einstellen
was übrigens bedeutet nicht nur dieser
schuljahr sondern auch weit noch ins
nächste schuljahr hinein
[Musik]